All right. It is the time of the week where
we get to Hatra at mail, a professional interpretive
reading of the Harriet Mail that I receive.
Quick reminder about Harriet Mail, because
if you aren't pro life, you deserve the death
penalty.
Teary eyed man written by patriots who hate
David Pakman. Because America. And because
freedom.
All right. A lot in this one. Many allegations.
Let's take a listen to it together.
Neo liberal shill David Pakman admits season
accomplice of Donald J. Trump David Pakman
is a shill for the new world order Illuminati
Lucifer Aryan cabal that is doing everything
in its power to destroy the United States.
Amy Robock knows that EPSTEIN was murdered.
David Pakman lies about Petes again as he
knows it's real. David Pakman you corporate
shill can wait until you go through with quitting
YouTube.
Yeah, you know this neo liberal thing just
lets assume it's not a troll and you really
think that I've become some kind of right
winger. Check out over the last 10 years on
the show every few years. I will do a bunch
of different political compass type tests
and every time I do it I have actually moved
to the left. I am more left today than I have
ever been before in my life. Now, as far as
you know, lied about Pizza Gate, quitting
YouTube, stuff like that. I don't know what
you're talking about, but if you really want
to do the homework and see have I become more
conservative or more left over the years?
The data is out there, my friend. Check it
out. Remember that you can use the coupon
code Hatra at 40 to save 40 percent off of
any membership at joint Packman dot com. The
coupon code is HKT r i o t for zero you save
40 percent. The hatred, its cry. I've seen
him do it every time that that coupon code
is used on my website.